I couldn't do what they hired me to do
is to teach philosophy all you would
need is a few students to make your life
hell and you know your colleagues
already buy into the ideology and they
have a vested interest in making sure
that the ideology is promulgated
throughout the institution and if you
don't adhere to those values it's not
like you're merely wrong it's that
you're a bad person
[Music]
hello and welcome to Marshall matters of
me Winston Marshall for The Spectator
today it is my privilege to speak to
Professor philosopher orpha former
professor at Portland State University
till a rather dramatic resignation in
September 2021 Peter bogosian Peter
thank you so much thank you appreciate
having having me on and getting to know
you over the last few days yeah we've
had some fun very cool if you wouldn't
mind maybe for listeners who aren't
familiar with your story yeah
maybe you can tell us why you resigned
from Portland State University sure so I
did my dissertation in the prisons with
prison inmates and it was using the
Socratic method which is a way of asking
people questions
to help the men and I say men because
everyone in my study at the time the
prison was Columbia River Correctional
Institution it was all male to help the
men desist from crime so they had tools
that they could use so then I took the
tools that I developed from my
dissertation and then I as you mentioned
the book I I turned the same Socratic
questioning tools to uh issues of
religious fundamentalism and issues of
Faith specifically and then I you I came
up with an app to teach people how to
have civil conversations that's the key
in this whole thing civil conversations
across divides
and and a book and and a book how to
have impossible conversations about the
same thing how to teach people how to
have civil conversations and now I with
read like we go around the world and we
do this thing called Spectrum Street
epistemology and epistemologist how you
know what you think you know and we give
people tools as part of my non-profit we
help them calibrate their beliefs to the
evidence they have okay so that's a
little background 2017
um well I first noticed a kind of uh
sickness in the academy in around 2012
the more I investigated the more I was
convinced it was from corrupt bodies of
scholarship peer-reviewed literature my
my writing partner and I James Lindsay
also co-author book with me we published
our first uh Circle Style hoax paper
which is basically to see what you can
get the most you can get in a journal
and we published a paper called the
conceptual penis as a social construct
in which we it's a very funny paper by
the way I I think it's very funny in
which we claim that among other things
penises were responsible for climate
change
and the paper got in and there were
there's a lot of criticism of the paper
you didn't do this you should have done
this you need more journals higher
ranking journals and so I said to Jim
okay they've given us a road map let's
follow that and then we so they assumed
it was serious and well yeah they
publish it as a serious pair like they
thought this was a it got past peer
review but our critics said well you
didn't you need to submit that to
journals in gender studies because I was
convinced at the time that the
ideological rot the corruption was
coming from very specific disciplines
and Fields fields that didn't try to
falsify hypotheses but tried to forward
narratives
so we publish or we we wrote with Helen
pluck Rose also wait sorry what type of
narrative what kind of fields do you
mean is that the grievance field is that
yeah fields that forward grievances or
that there's just there's racism baked
into the systems
postcolonial theory basically
post-modernism and all its uh Helen
pluck Rose calls it applied
post-modernism so almost anything with
the word studies in it the purpose of
those disciplines isn't to
do what one would think that one does in
science which is to figure out what's
true test hypotheses use the best most
rigorous methods available but the
purpose is to forward very specific
conclusions about the world and get
those conclusions implemented and
adopted to change public policies and
their activism essentially yeah it's
it's yeah it's even worse than activism
because it's not predicated upon
something that's true it's predicated on
complete nonsense how do you think they
got into the university those those uh
different studies
uh how did my our papers get in those
those things yeah do we go back to the
Frankfurt School do we go how does this
leak into the American Academy oh boy
that's a long conversation
um it okay so I'll give you the spark
notes of the cliff notes version of it
so
as a general rule people like people who
are like themselves people hire people
in an academy
who have similar ideological
dispositions similar positions about
issue similar stances
and so I mean you can see that it just
rang through my mind you can see that
for example in Psychology when
behaviorism is in behaviors would hire
other behaviors because they think it's
true
so let's talk about idea laundering for
a moment this is a key concept idea
laundry idea laundering like money
laundering money goes in
dirty money goes in corrupt money goes
in
and they they call it laundering because
it used to be in New York with all the
laundry machines and then
it goes out laundered and in that it
looks it's all good for the taxes so you
could spend it right so you can write
write checks for apartments or what have
you the same thing is operative in
an ideological sense or a sense with
peer-reviewed studies and peer-reviewed
journals people have a moral impulse a
bunch of people get together who have a
similar moral impulse they start a
journal people publish people also with
that moral impulse publish in those
journals these are not true they're not
facts they're not anything they're just
musings usually of ideologues people
have this idea they publish it and it
comes out as a peer-reviewed journal
the more of those you get published as a
general rule it's seven papers in seven
years and you get tenure so what happens
is that
that when you publish in in specific
journals and specific fields and it was
out of the stem Fields now it's
increasingly within the stem fields
you're more likely to get tenure when
you're more likely to get tenure you
hire other people who have similar
beliefs so it's in it's called a
promotion in tenure basket so you
publish an article in a grieving studies
field
in a journal which is already corrupt to
begin with but it looks on paper as if
you're publishing and making a
contribution to the literature
so if so slowly the academy was that's
one explanation there are multiple
explanations that's why it's I pause to
think it's a very complicated problem it
the other
we could literally do a whole podcast on
this the other problem is that
educational administrators were hired
universally who have ed school degrees
we did a series on this with Lyle ashes
why are colleges becoming Cults and the
ideas that are forwarded are certain
ideas that are inherent in critical race
Theory without using the words critical
race Theory so oppressive systemic power
imbalances oppressive structures we need
Heather McDonald just has a new book
about that from the Manhattan Institute
um but this is a problem that has
consumed the academy and the quest the
question now is how do we get out of it
because virtually nobody disagrees that
this is a problem
anybody who would look at the it that we
could look at it from cancellations we
could look at it from sorry uh
and it seems like your careers that you
you were caught in the crossfires where
those ideas were brewing for a long time
and stewing for a long time and then and
you and you started to question those
and but you say
no one would disagree that those are a
problem yeah and one of the things I'm
trying to work out is is this coming
from the students or is it coming from
the the teachers the professors and and
because
if if no one agrees it's if everyone
agrees it's a problem yeah then surely
we wouldn't be in a situation where you
had to quit
yeah okay so so what I meant by nobody I
should have articulated myself nobody
who's independent who looks at the
problem independently would say wow
there's no problem here move along and
anybody who questions
I mean even asked the question you know
where where's the evidence for this I
was constantly accused of
microaggressions asking for evidence
became a microaggression
um if if if you have a belief if you
want to Institute a policy for whatever
the policy is that students need safe
spaces or the trigger warning should be
on syllabi these are just in an academic
context
if somebody says to you okay so you
think we should do this institutionally
what is the data for this what is the
data so even if you pointed to a a
peer-reviewed journal that itself had
been ideal laundered right the the the
discharging of the moral impulse by some
ideologue you should still be able to
point to that but the idea that this is
somehow a universal truth
which is weird for people who don't
believe in Universal truths but
um this is somehow a universal truth
and everybody needs to adopt it and
nobody is allowed to ask about any
evidence for this
that alone even if it's true that
they're even if there were evidence from
microaggressions trigger warning State
spaces belonging whatever it is
you should be able to provide that
evidence
it seems ridiculous that that philosophy
that or that means of operating could
Infiltrate The University it's the
antithesis of what one thinks the
university is for yeah so to understand
that you have to understand how
groups of smart people
so so and Michael schurmer writes about
this in the believing brain and I love
this I talk about it all the time it's
one of my favorite quotations
um why smart people believe weird things
because they're better at reasoning to
bad conclusions so they're better at
offering good reasons for bad
conclusions groups of smart people are
better still so it's precisely because
there are academics that they were
better at writing to was morally
fashionable so you have a bunch of
people who are defending
the dominant moral Orthodoxy um
uh-huh and then that's how that becomes
institutionalized that's how you get the
wide scale adoption of that they're not
questioning they're not and and and
there's a a reward mechanism in place
you get a job for life you know you you
go up in the promotion ladder Etc can
you explain to me peer review and how
that operates because I learned this or
heard this rather recently from uh
listen to Eric Weinstein and his
scathing criticisms of peer reviews I'm
not sure that's correct understood
because it got you quite a new uh peer
review didn't exist am I right until
about 50 years ago if I a little more
than that but yeah so so the idea is
that so this publishing all kinds of
publishing there's publishing on sub
stack which you know basically
publishing on a Blog there's publishing
a Zine or a magazine there's getting an
article published for example in the
Atlantic or Scientific American or what
have you
or just go and walk terribly walk and
then there's peer review peer review is
a different animal so peer review
you submit an article
to an editor who runs a journal and the
journal would be like you know Journal
of fat studies which is one of our
journals
right which doesn't do what you think it
does the goal of fat studies is not to
measure a1cs or talk about you know carb
carbs and protein what is the gold of
that study the the goal of fat studies
is to advocate for fat acceptance and to
claim that you and that obese to claim
that obesity is a narrative pushed by
the medical profession and you can be
healthy at any size that's the brief
encapsulation of fat study that's
actually studied in universities in
America well it's a journal a
peer-to-view journal run by a woman
named Charlotte Cooper out of your
Island there the UK so sorry yeah I'm I
am I am as well who herself happens to
be morbidly obese not necessarily that
that explains anything but the uh
overwhelming preponderance the
overwhelming number of proponents are
females the authors of these journals
and most of whom I've seen are morbidly
obese and so they don't like the word so
every so if you think of the world is
everything being a narrative a narrative
is just a story everybody has their own
narratives medicine has their narratives
you know rappers have their everybody
banjo players I don't know anything
about banjo
okay so everybody has their own
narrative so
um The Narrative of obesity
the word obesity itself captures a
medical narrative they don't want the
word obesity to use they want the word
fat used
so because it's less offensive to them
um no because they believe that you can
be healthy at any size
and if you say obesity that's an
inherently bad thing that's that's
something that
buys into a medical understanding of a
physical phenomenon so think about it
like this Nietzsche says that there are
no there are no moral phenomena only
moral interpretations of phenomenon so
being fat so if I brought in a person
who was like 400 pounds here
and you affixed a word to that person
you know fat morbidly obese whatever the
word was that would be a judgment on
your part of the physical phenomena I
say fat is used just as much as an
offensive time as obesity or as a
negative term as obesity is it not no
for them obesity is the more offense
yeah yeah it's not just defensive but
it's it's um
it's the ascription of a
medical again narrative a medical
perception of the world onto a fat body
okay so it's pretty stupid about to pay
a review that's the other thing is this
stuff is just so stupid I mean it's just
idiotic and it's the proponents of it
are almost exclusively have mediocre
Minds it's just too stupid to sustain
itself it's just too idiotic okay so
you're rather pessimistic then about
so the idea is that for example in the
Journal fat studies you get other people
who have published in the journal and so
they become experts in the field so
somebody should be blind in other words
the reviewer should know who it is look
at the article and the best people try
to vet that article to see whether or
not it should go into the journal
based upon if it meets certain criteria
for the journal right if is it scholarly
rigorous is it this but in most of these
journals and I do use that word
very specifically it should be virtually
all but I'll just
tone it down to say most the idea is
that you want certain conclusions to
percolate into the broader culture and
the way that you do that is that you
you have certain starting assumptions so
if you want to get a paper published you
write to those starting assumptions
they're a systemic the whole system is
corrupt there's you know racism
everywhere whatever the whatever the
starting assumption is it doesn't have
to be something within the suite of bulk
ideology it could be you know
something about Barbers or what have you
but we don't we don't have those it's
only things that deal with identity
level salience specifically gender race
sexual orientation things of that nature
okay so is do you think it's fed then
that the the universities for me to
think it's completely rotten these ideas
have completely taken over yes
infiltrated everything correct that's
presumably you know you describe in your
resignation that you were even spat on
yeah when you're there but actually it
seems perhaps that you left maybe
because you've just given up hope that
the University functioned
as it's supposed to function as a place
for three foot and quiet well I couldn't
do what they hired me to do is to teach
philosophy I was getting complaints
constantly about everything when I
challenged you you couldn't even present
the other side of an issue
now that's not with every single student
but all you would need is a few students
to make your life hell and you know your
colleagues already buy into the ideology
and they have a vested interest in
making sure that the ideology is
promulgated throughout the institution
and the larger society and if you don't
adhere to those values it's not like
you're merely wrong it's that you're a
bad person there's something endemically
flawed with you and you need to go
through some kind of re-education or
you're just you know
be redeemable but you are now part of
some whatever academic fight back with
the University of Austin who actually
are in Austin now as we speak
um can you tell me about the University
of Austin and why it's so important
it's a university predicated upon
what traditional universities have
always been truth seeking
um it's run its present as Pano canulus
Joe Lonsdale the entrepreneur is on the
board of directors Barry Weiss from Free
Press is on the board of directors
um
faculty or ion or CLE Neil Ferguson from
your Island a different part of your
Island historian
um Kathleen stock also from your Island
she's a very brave woman a lot of
extremely Brave woman similar to you
forced to leave higher University being
hounded by the trans idea correct yeah
correct yeah so that's another type of
derangement that maybe we could go into
a little bit but so it's a it's a
university we have the Forbidden I'm
coming back in June for the Forbidden
classes Kathleen stock is going to be
here as well for the Forbidden classes
um David Mamet Etc it's really a
fascinating group of people they've
assembled like genuinely interesting
people and the university is set to open
in 2024 in Austin The Forbidden classes
are in Dallas this summer okay and
you're going to be there right I am I'll
be there in June uh doing I think a
question and answers so thank you so I'm
I'm a Believer in in that uh I I I've
I've noticed this stuff and the academy
for for what for a while even though I I
didn't actually go to university but I
um I like the idea of building I think
we need to build new institutions so I
think that's the correct response
there's one which idea is that we need
to change and I kind of wanted to ask
whether there's a new generation of
teachers and students going into the
long existing universities who might be
able to change who rebel against these
ideologies that you'll be discussing or
whether we need to build new
institutions completely and that you
know I'm not sure which is right maybe
it's both okay
so before I say that I I will make a
prediction you are going to love the
students I mean amazing faculty since
the level of intellectual engagement
that you'll find this summer is
phenomenal like off the charts crazy and
what I particularly like with the
students is just to hang out so you know
we go to these classes and then come
back and it just I mean it was very
intense and they really are completely
curious yeah okay so now back to the
institution so there are two ways to
look at the problem
one way is the way that I believe is
that they're irredeemable and you have
to build new things
the other way is Chris ruffo's way and
he's with the Manhattan Institute and he
believes that reform is still possible
once you kick out the Dei bureaucrats so
let's lay that terrain a little bit
let's explain explain that so
it is not possible
it is not possible to have both Dei and
Free Speech you either get Dei or you
get free speech anything else
you see you have a simple choice so
anybody making a Chicago statement or
this declaration it's just not true it's
Harvard uh put something up about that
reason they have it's never going to
work it's literally impossible because
the whole mission of Dei is to limit
what people say so they won't so certain
minorities won't be won't quote unquote
feel excluded the whole I the whole
premise of it is that that the system is
inherently racist
um everything from who gets into the
institutions and universities SAT scores
the whole it's just not possible so you
have the Chris Ruffo idea now here's the
interesting thing
so in 1945 Carl Parker also from your
Island Austrian English the philosopher
of science has a wonderful thing on the
Paradox of Tolerance and the Paradox of
Tolerance is the idea that
to what extent should the tolerance
tolerate the intolerant so on a taking
it out of the academy so for example the
Netherlands right now or actually London
to to an extent but
um Sweden
to what extent should broadly liberal
societies tolerate pockets of Islamic
radicalism people who are
you know in those views about
homosexuality those views about covering
of women Etc and so what we have so this
is how I view this system you have a
group of people
who participate in ideology that
ideology has metastasized throughout the
educational system
not only do they control bureaucracies
but they have a direct path to the
president usually there's a kind of
hierarchical organization in which one
files a complaint or what have you have
to go but the Dei goes right to the top
they are offices searching for tasks
with the assumption that sexism and
racism already exists and bigotry and
homophobia rank bias of some sort and we
just need to figure out how it manifests
that's a tenant that's a underlying
principle of critical race Theory so to
what extent do we tolerate the
intolerance and so rufo is going after
and he's being very effective he's
working with Ron DeSantis right now and
I hope he's successful and the criticism
of rufo I don't think holds the
criticism is you're trying to do things
that woke people are doing on the
opposite end so will people live sorry
so rufo was going in and eliminating Dei
bureaucracy so we can have more of a
classically liberal education okay the
problem is you just have to make sure
that those aren't staffed by only people
who have another ideology a similar
ideology right so so the criticism of
rufo then is that
what he's doing is he's replacing one
ideology with another okay and and
that's certainly something to be mindful
of
but the idea then that once these Dei
bureaucrats are kicked out and this is a
very significant uh you know in Stanford
for example
um
it's almost a two to one student ratio
with diversity bureaucrats and these
have these are enormously
um well-funded departments and
individual positions are very highly
paid so this is not a it trivially a
financially trivial matter
so to what extent should we tolerate the
intolerant when the very people once
they get kicked out from the Dei
bureaucracy they're screaming about Free
Speech the very people who are taking
away everybody else's free speech so I
hope rufo is successful I don't know if
he'll be but I'm not going to wait and
find out I'm going to build new things
I'm going to make an institution I'm
going to help contribute to an
institution that's based upon free
speech and open inquiry and genuine
curiosity where people who have
questions can ask without fear of you
know cancellation or being you know just
a priori repudiated is something someone
says that's the interesting debate that
we're having in Britain as well about
and CRT in in schools not just in
universities but for those of us who
believe in free speech how do we how do
we deal with CRT and you know the
Banning of it all together how do we get
rid of it if or how can we say with
pro-free speech if we don't somehow
tolerate it and maybe that's Pat true or
the tolerance Paradox but how how do how
does one deal with that or does that
mean that you're not actually a free
speech absolutist okay so let's let's
take a look at this because I think
that's an excellent question so let's
let's Linger on this and drill down it
so I'm going to give you some examples
of ideologies and and
so for you know phrenology with the
bumps on the skull the Nazis were big
into that and they believe it was
predictive of intelligence and race and
all this other silliness which is simply
not it's
you had a group of people in a school
system who wanted to institutionalize
phenology
and so they would give scholarships
based upon people who had certain
protrudences in their head you you had
these people who had classes in
phrenology they taught phenology it was
throughout the curricula
should we allow phrenology
in the schools and if you say no we
don't want to allow phrenology in the
schools does that make you someone who's
against free speech
you don't have to answer I know I'm
putting you on the spot but let me give
you another one
so bracket that we can come back to that
later
let's say that we have so phrenology is
an idiotic ideology is it harmful I
don't know maybe a little bit but
okay now let's let's that's another way
of taking it right is that Nazism is an
evil ideology yeah that's where I was
going next yeah so one and and one needs
to teach children about what happened
and maybe it comes in a history class
right you know rather than a philosophy
class we don't teach Nazi philosophy but
we're in touch what this is and maybe
that's another way of of dealing it I
guess the bigger problem with
CRT is it's not really so much it's
certainly not a history although there's
a history of the philosophy but it's a
way of seeing the world and actually
everything else is seen through those
correct prism so it's kind of like a
whole other uh
problem right okay so okay okay so let's
let's go down that road
so you have a few things going on
we got the phrenology thing that we've
bracketed now let's say that somebody
wants to teach some pretty Insidious
stuff right so
Nazi ideology what have you let's just
use that's the gold standard for bad
right
and if we attempt to kick those people
out who want to institutionalize this
who are actually effectively
institutionalizing this does that mean
we're against free speech and what if
they say hey you're trying to kick us
out you know Z Kyle you know you're just
violating my rights to free speech
so so so you
that's the that's the Paradox of
Tolerance right that's the idea if to
what extent should we leverage
institutional mechanisms in the system
and at this case of rufo and DeSantis
we're talking at the state level right
to kick out to change the Board of
Trustees to then go out and extirpate
the entire Dei bureaucracy
I would argue that you're not violating
and I realized that many people are
going to listen to say oh this is some
kind of right wing say no it's it's not
at all you would do that with literally
any other ideology and just because the
ideology happens to compote with your
beliefs it doesn't make it okay that
it's institutionalized and the other
thing is why is an ideology it's not
falsifiable mm-hmm
it's simply not falsified at least
phenology is falsifiable a couple of
times through this conversation you've
used the word woke yeah which I think is
a pejorative term yeah and uh but very
basic question because it seems to be uh
some
debate about this or or stumbling on
this the definition of what when you use
the term woke simple question but what
do you mean
I mean it's actually very easy to
understand
it's not even remotely complicated at
all it's that there are systemic
injustices the people who people who are
awoke to people who are awoke you can
never be woke enough I did a one minute
series of videos where I explain words
that woke people use in one minute
it means that you have a an awareness of
systemic Injustice it means that that
Injustice is somehow rooted in the
system and usually
that almost always but not always that
revolves around some kind of something
with an identity level salience race
um gender sexual orientation trans
status Etc isn't it that seems like
quite a complex because I've just I've
seen it as really just excessive
progressivism and yeah I mean so it's
not too simple yeah I mean look you
people have called it Wesley Ann calls
it the successor ideology uh Majid nuaz
calls it regressive leftism Helen
pluckrose calls it critical social
justice I usually use social justice
uppercase s and you guys it goes by
different names and and they basically
mean the same thing do you think in
America are we yet to have Peak woke a
weep in the woke Clash where where do we
think you we sit now in in the history
of of wokism where do you think we
peaked I think we've peaked but the
damage that it's done to the
institutions is nowhere near over hmm
like what would you what do you foresee
well I mean the police force I see the
American cities uh uh uh the more wokes
you know the mayor of Portland for
example is a Public Disgrace Ted wheeler
he him uh I see
I right that's just a kind of signaling
right so he's he's more concerned about
I mean he really should be concerned ex
almost exclusively with rampant crime
300 increase in murders homelessness
drug addiction you know helping the
people who who need help who are on the
streets but instead he has a and it's
not just wheeler it's just this strain
of and and DA's on Prosecuting crimes
and
it's it's a systemic breakdown but I
think that we are past Peak woke and
I'll give you some pieces of evidence
for that well I'll tell you one of the
things a few things that's changed I
think that the our brains are wired for
testimony and so the testimonies of
detransitioners I think it's some pretty
ghastly stuff and most but not all those
people are have a girl Sharia writes
about this in irreversible damage these
are basically young gay kids told that
they're born in the wrong body and then
they they need to transition I heard
Katie Herzog say in an event once that
she's she's gay
and she said that there are no her her
her I think she termed it Femme friends
said that there are no Butch lesbians
anymore they've all transitioned wow
okay actually there's a Hannah Barnes
was in the book yeah um time to think
about it was happening in Britain and
she shows it's it's something like of
the female trans it's oh it's over 80
percent are gay and of and I think if
the male trans is over 90 it's highly
and then very high autism autism
um and uh and that's also it's changed
over time I think in the last 15 years
it was a majority a male phenomenon and
now it's become a majority female
phenomenon but uh so that that's sort of
it's it's changing and continues to
change and it's by age group as well
which essentially Deborah so and Colin
Wright right about this it's by certain
age groups younger people who are more
susceptible to this in certain counties
you know up to you know fifteen twenty
percent uh in California I can't
remember the name of the county so you
you have so Jason D Hill puts the the
figure at .06 of the people are trans
and so anything other than that you have
to ask why is it that we're more lacks
and Society doesn't care anymore so
people who are hiding it but again I
just want to be Crystal clear as I have
to be in every one of these interviews
anybody can lead any type of Life they
want and if you want to be trans you
should absolutely knock yourself out and
you should live a free life nobody
should that's absolutely inexcusable to
harass someone or grief someone Etc
people should live any lives they want
I'm talking about something very
different I'm talking about a few things
specifically I'm talking about
transitioning children before they're
18. right and and specifically hiding
that from parents my my son wanted to
die his hair when he was 17. he needed a
note from his parents you know this
Lupine the hormone there's chest binding
there's so I'm talking about a very
specific thing and then I'm also talking
about
um trans women in sports and I'm talking
about trans women in prisons uh or or
women's only spaces more broadly but
specifically I'm talking about uh the
detransitioners of your own kids and I
think that's one of the things
it's not going to be the cancellations
it's not going to be people realize
fundamentally there's something ghastly
about mutilating the genitals of
children absolutely and you see the
photographs I don't know how anyone
could possibly look at that and and
think otherwise and and I just want to
linger on that for a second but that's
why my prediction to you is that
once the ideology falls into ill-repute
or disrepute what you'll see is epic
gaslighting and you're starting to see
it now which is also why I see it I
never believe that this is not nobody
wants to defund the police there's an
article in the New York Times Yes we
really do mean abolish the police and
the same people are saying well so I
think that there's going to be why maybe
disgrave you on this yeah in Britain I
think we're we're past Peak trans
ideology yeah uh and The Madness of it
and again I'm I have agreed of
everything you said I'm I would never
you can identifies anti-transites Pro
women and also Pro protecting children
right right but and at The Ballot Box
for example and this we had this in
Scotland Nicholas sturgeon had to leave
the leadership of the Scottish national
party yeah yeah uh because she was
unable to answer the question what is a
woman people see that and they go are
you insane even leader of the opposition
in England and Britain sorry kirstama
says 99.9 of of women don't have a penis
as in one in a thousand do right and and
people see that and you go insane and
it's unpopular about us but here in this
country
I see someone like Dylan Mulvaney and
there's I don't see the same backlash
for here I don't see people I see
certainly conservatives and I see a
women's rights activists digging in
their heels and upset about it but I
don't see ideas being changed it just
seems that people are just doubling down
in their own little silos
yeah it's difficult I can't I can't say
I just Reed and I just came back from
Australia and we we had some pretty
interesting meetings and
we met with Deans and heads of think
tanks and reporters and as we walked out
of that meeting the thing that I said to
myself was that I said to myself was wow
these are just like they're almost
exactly a year behind just they're just
wait until it comes from them and as I
walked out Reed said that exact same
thing to me it's like well just give
give it a year wait a year yeah so so I
can't I can't speak I can say it when
I've been in Europe
um that curve is about and we should
probably maybe we want to talk about how
woke ideology spreads in non-english
speaking countries yes that's very
interesting how does it spread it
normally because it's starting to happen
now in Europe it's been very much The
Preserve of the anglosphere for a while
and I'm starting to see it in France as
a pushback and it's and I think it's
because gender self ideas coming into
place and that seems to me to be the
back door that woke ideology is coming
into into non-english speaking Europe
would you agree with that or
um okay so so and macron is doing some
interesting stuff with that um and I but
although I have to say I don't like his
recent posture approach China and
against the United States that are our
old venerable friendship so okay so I
published a piece in November 8th in The
Spectator about this so so this is kind
of it took me a long time to think about
this when I was in Austria I gave a talk
with lawyers and I said this is coming
in six months and basically everybody
laughed at me and then I went back in
six months and the same guy one of the
guys who laughed me came I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry so let's talk about
hobokeness spreads so for wokeness to
work it needs
one thing
it needs a double meaning of a word it
means that that means that one woke word
has to have two meanings
it has to have the meaning in common
parlance and it has to have the woke
meaning
so this is referred to as the Mott we
spoke about this briefly The Mott and
the Bailey the Bailey is
the way that woke people use the words
The Mott is the way that normal people
use the words like Equity inclusion is a
good one include we want everyone of
course you want people to be included
and so
what happens is in like when I was in
Hungary or um Austria or basically any
place any any place outside the Anglo
sphere
and that includes India as well
when you translate a woke word into
another language
the only thing that translates is The
Mott is the primary meaning of the word
the secondary meaning of the word
doesn't it can't translate it doesn't
translate so the consequence of that is
that in order for woke to infect a
system and spread throughout the system
it has to be an English word
so interesting so what is which words
are then adding hitting the consonant
the same words that we use in English
diversity Equity inclusion blind the
whole list triggers the whole thing use
the English word they use English words
now woke can work in any language but
English is the language of woke and so
you you can't like if you did that in
German or Hungarian or what have you it
just wouldn't it people it wouldn't make
any sense and then when it made it into
public policy documents people would say
well look we know the definition of the
word what are you talking about but when
it makes it into a public policy
definition in the anglo-sphere then the
woke people go to the Bailey they go to
the woke definition of the word and it's
too late at that point because it's
already in public policy
so interesting yeah there's uh perhaps
zooming out a little bit but back to the
the idea of work you before we started
recording you talked about so you gave
me the impression you should have given
up and engaging in conversation with the
woke which is striking given that you've
written a whole book right about how to
engage and and dig into the epistemology
of woke thought and and uh and and how
to have positive conversations indeed
the book is called how to have
constructive conversations
um and yet you have seemed to have given
up have you given up okay no no so let
me clarify this is really important so
we're talking about by and large a group
of people who believe that dialogue and
discourse are inherently not only racist
in and of themselves but they it's
called privilege preserving epistemic
pushback the person who is engaged in
the dialogue it is just a way they're
only engaged in the dialogue it's a way
to maintain power and if you're a work
person I don't want to give that point
for you know platforming a
non-consensual core platforming I don't
want to engage that person to amplify
their voice to hurt marginalized people
so it is a choice they themselves have
made to not engage their people with
whom they have some ideological
disagreement but the consequence of that
ultimately is that it's a memetic device
to prevent the ideology from any kind of
penetration from anything that could
dislodge the ideology or could decrease
the confidence that any of the
propositions in the suite beliefs that
the ideology holds is true so it's not
that I won't engage it's that any time
that those there are any and they're not
even engagements they're just kind of ad
hominem attacks um
that's essentially because one of the
things I found having read your book I
read it a few years ago is actually
unless both parties read the book right
only one of them one of you read the
book it's very hard to you need to get
both people to approach the conversation
in that way so are you leaving are you
sort of is there a follow-up where it's
like the conversation's over yeah so
that's the thing about an impossible
conversation a conversation
an impossible conversation you you can
have a conversation with someone who has
a radically different metaphysical
belief about you know angels and all
this or whatever Miracle different
political belief it doesn't matter what
it is when I taught in prisons the
concern was never that
people would disagree with me or you
know say you know Screw you with the
middle finger the concern was always
that they wouldn't say anything because
if they don't say anything there's
nothing to hook on to there's no
conversation so you know if someone
doesn't want to have a conversation with
you you can't kidnap them put them in
your trunk and beat them until they want
to talk to you that's a literally
impossible conversation so the
conversation is impossible if no one
wants to have a conversation with you
okay let's see can also zooming out
again yeah yeah so as a prominent new
atheist thinker writer yeah and speaker
I wondered if you might see a link
between did the new atheists clear that
we've talked about trans we've talked
about yeah woke I would throw in
environmentalism and there's one of
these new quasi pseudo-religions Michael
Schoenberg Beyond Lundberg talk about
that absolutely do you think I would it
would be unfair for me to say that the
new atheists perhaps cleared a path
by killing God yes again yes
um for these new religions to these new
quasi-religions pseudo religions to
flourish 100 percent absolutely true and
I think there was a
pollyann attitude that many new atheists
had
that somehow will will bury God by
return of phrase Nietzsche and
everybody's going to be living in some
rational Paradise
little did anybody know at that point
although the canaries in the coal mine
were in the new atheist movement the
skeptical Movement we started to see
this in the very beginning
that what would replace it would be
horrific I mean would just be
I mean look look look look with the kind
of things that we're dealing with now
and so that it's called the substitution
hypothesis I can never remember if I
came up with this or Peterson or my
apartment I don't really remember where
this comes from but the idea is that
it's a substitution hypothesis so one
it's like Game of Thrones you know you
only you ever watch Game of Thrones no
you're kidding me I
uh this is a recommendation oh yeah wow
that's just amazing to me you should
begin immediately but but anyway uh you
the only reason that you have new Gods
is because people don't believe in the
old gods anymore right so the so the
substitution hypothesis is when you get
rid of the abrahamic Traditions or
whatever's traditional religion in a
country something else will come in some
other form of irrationality or will come
in and substitute for what was lost
because the default is you just have to
believe in some rationality or or
religion it doesn't have to be
irrational does it or another no it
would happen
well it would have to be a world view
that wasn't substantiated by the
evidence because that's what substitutes
it okay so with
if you're fighting now not just as you
were fighting the universities you're
fighting across the world to defeat
these new
pseudo-religions what are you going to
replace them with oh that that's uh that
that's the a great question the first
thing you have to do is you have to
replace them with the institutions that
have been corrupted right so you have to
replace them at the University of
Austin's for example that's that's brick
and mortar so to speak what about the
artist okay so okay so let's let's take
let's take a hierarchical look at this
there's Theory institutions Downstream
of that is belief right so there's the
theory I'm talking about the beliefs I
want to understand that right so so the
way that people get the belief is from
the theory through the institutions then
they start believing it
so if you change the institutional
structures if you change the way that
the academies are function and running
Downstream of that that's why there's a
there's a woke contagion the woke
contagion started in
um it's well it actually starts in K-12
but the way that you teaching K-12 as
you go through a College of Education
College of Education are predicated not
upon seeking truth but alleviating
oppression that's a ubiquitous
phenomenon at every Edge School in the
country
okay so the way that you change the
beliefs at the bottom there are two ways
one is Street epistemology there are
actually three or four ways but but one
is Street epistemology what what we do
in our video and our our you couldn't
explain why that is because I've seen
the videos but yeah so Street
epistemology is a way to it's a
non-conference confrontational
non-adversarial way to have better
conversations to help people and
yourself reflect upon the confidence in
your beliefs and whether that confidence
is warranted by the reason and evidence
you have for believing it so you're
going out in the street yeah all the
strangers together never no actors 100
random people strangers everywhere we
just got back from Reading I just got
back from Australia we just got back
from Florida we just got back from
Puerto Rico we're going to go to your
Island next and what we do is we just
put tape on the ground from strongly
disagree
disagree slightly disagree neutral to
the strongly agree we ask people what
they want to talk about and we take
epistemology what it is how you know
what you know out of the universities
and we bring it to the streets and we
give people tools that they can use to
not only have civil conversations but to
figure out if they're warranted or
justified in the confidence of their
beliefs we just did a really interesting
one the other day with a young girl we
don't usually we never do people under
18 because you need parental permission
to
view but her mom was there and the claim
was Miley Cyrus was the best singer ever
I never really I mean I heard so I
couldn't tell you I listened to Tool and
heavy metal I couldn't tell you one song
Miley Cyrus said you know who Miley
Cyrus is I I I'm a great Mara of her
music yeah that's just a great talent in
uh okay well I know Apartments I know
nothing about her like wrecking ball you
know wrecking ball it's a great song I
listen to heavy metal I don't know any
of this we'll have a little wrecking
ball session like Miley well I don't
know if that I don't know if I know you
well enough to want that but
did I do something wrong I don't know no
no no no just on my side so so she you
know her claim was Miley Cyrus is the
best and she stood on the strongly agree
um but after only a few questions in a
few minutes you know she went to the
agree just targeted Socratic questions
to help her think to help her give her a
tool and I told her mom's like you can
do this with her with anybody you could
just at work so anyway so the one one of
the ways Downstream what replaces this
is it is you give people tools so that
they can lead a better life and this is
a way that the word Community is
actually applicable they can help their
communities sorry that's wonderful and
actually it's particularly effective
seeing is you're filming it so people
can watch it and it and it's it's free
yeah and it's free but you know I think
my question
sort of without being sort of too rude
don't worry anything you want to know
believe me we're getting rid of a
pseudo-religion yeah
the and the the
I don't know I don't quite Street
epistemology great as it is I can't see
how that's going to be a new it's not
it's not no no it's not okay so
so the older I get here if I can tell
you one conclusion I've come up with in
the 56 years of my life
going on 57.
it's that
the best way to make a positive change
isn't either in the way people believe
things or
the way society's ebb and flow it's
through values
and so
what people value matters
and if you believe that certain things I
believe and I my guess is that you
believe
and as we explore our friendship I'll
come over time to figure out if you
actually do believe this is that certain
values you can value certain things to
lead you to a good life and you can
value certain things to lead your
community to flourish
and if once you admit that then you can
you have to admit by necessity certain
things you can value lead against your
own well-being and that of your
communities and so
we have to give people tool sets to
enable them to Value the right things
but even before you do that you have to
think about that Structure Theory
institutions people right now what's
happening is the reason that people's
beliefs are there instead of people well
what people and what they believe so you
they have the theory the theory informs
the institutions in K-12 and colleges of
Education the people in those academic
in that academic meal you think of the
academy as an ideology meal where they
want to replicate this ideology and they
teach that to students the first order
of business is to shut shut that
replication process how this idea makes
sense to me is in fact as I say is
almost that's how the critical theory
has managed to come and attack those
greater beliefs we have but really in
essence it's it's built the other way
those great institutions didn't come
from Theory institutions and they came
the other way around whereas belief then
we build institutions and then theory on
top of that that's how it was
constructed so right if we're we're
dealing with the belief itself
I can see how that's a good way to to
attack the new beliefs the new religions
right is the same tactic but I'm talking
about the the beliefs themselves at the
court if we're going to eventually
defeat these uh ideas that we dislike
which as I've now said a few times are
new religions right what what are you
religion to replace okay so this is
extremely important
Okay so
the difference is at some level in a
religious architecture at some level at
least in the Christian tradition the
Islamic tradition isn't the case you
need some kind of a faith-based belief
you need some kind of us of a way if if
you're in if you have you know if you
believe that you have eight confidence
in something or even nine if you believe
that you have eight evidence on a scale
from one to ten but your confidence is
nine
you there's a difference between The
Confident the evidence you have and the
confidence you have that slack is
usually called Faith Like It's Made Up
by something but in the new religion
critical social justice workers and
whatever you want to call you whatever
you want to call it ultimately you have
bodies of peer-reviewed literature which
are corrupt we've just discussed that
that they can point to so they don't
need any faith like ultimately someone
who's versed in this can point to it and
then it percolates throughout so it's
not so
there has to be some prophylactics in
place to prevent people from bleeding
other drained things right so I don't
know what's going to come after wilkism
I have a a very strong suspicion about
what the next culture war will be about
and the next cultural war will be about
whether or not and people who are
ordinarily strong bed fellows like
Christians and atheists weren't but now
they are most of my supporters are
actually Christians but the next culture
War I predict will be
those who want to save Legacy
institutions and those who want to
destroy them Stephen Pinker wants to
save them I want to destroy them so that
will be the next culture War so it's not
like it's the substitution it's an
intracultural world that's a war amongst
the people who agree with this ideology
some of these certain ideologies we've
been calling them woke going too far
right that's not a cultural Place let's
say the transcultural because that's
this is within the anti-work community
no no I call it I think I think that
these I could be totally wrong about
this I would be completely wrong I think
we'll this whole thing is gonna it's
just so idiotic I just cannot believe
it's just it's sustainable I I'm amazed
that it's gone this far but I don't see
this being around in 10 years I see it
being replaced by and of course you know
a few nukes in American cities could
change everything immediately which is
part of the other problem you know I try
never to even mention Dylan Mulvaney I
don't even like the fact that I
mentioned it or sorry I brought him up
no no no that's fine but the the the
problem is then that that is a failure
the obsession with drag shows Etc it's a
failure to morally triage or even
socially and politically triage the
problems we have like Portland Oregon
Portland Oregon is becoming a huge
Cesspool homelessness drug addiction uh
crime on a national level we have
inflation we have problems to Ukraine
war we should simply not be talking
about Dylan Mulvaney it's it's insane
you know it's Douglas Mario our mutual
friends it's like it's you know people
are trying to sneak nukes in and
everybody's worried about everybody's
pronouns but I think that that it's not
that one religion will replace another
religion it's that if people value
certain things that will lead their
Community flourishing and these are not
particularly difficult things in fact I
would argue they're all rationally
drivable compassion basic human decency
civility if you don't like a statue
that's fine you petition through
Democratic process to have the statue
removed there's no like thug rule where
if you don't like a deer in Portland
they've ripped down you know they rip
down the Abraham Lincoln Statue you said
earlier in this conversation that it's
all about narrative and all of these
ideas have a narrative and this there's
truth to that we will function with the
narrative whichever as individuals or
our narrative and that greater narrative
science can't fill that right that new
narrative we need a
again I would say it's a metaphysic on
which to build build it all and okay so
I'm hammering perhaps okay too much the
same point no no no so if you have a
metaphysic
and and so let's say that one's
metaphysical they believe that there's
some kind of a supernatural realm
populated by all these entities or they
believe that
through in the time space continuum
there are certain points that that a
godhead or some kind of divine
being came in and intervened and
somebody walked on water or you know
bread and Loaves wine water or whatever
it is healed people whatever it is
those
those phenomenon those phenomena are
usually grounding for the value system
in other words if you don't have those
then you can't have the value system and
I'm telling you in no uncertain terms
that is simply not true okay well so
tell me because that's exactly what the
argument I'm making what how is that not
true
laughs
so
if it is the case so let's say so so you
have
so there are two possibilities right
there's a possibility that that that and
that and let's say we don't know what
Universe we're living in right there's a
possibility where
a Creator intervened in the space-time
Continuum and did these things that are
we termed miracles
and let's say that you don't know if
you're in that universe or you're not in
that Universe my question to you is
would the value still hold
and I would say to you that the values
independent of the universe in which you
knew you're in the values many of those
values would still hold
how you treat people treating people
with kindness being a decent human being
why would those values still hold well
because you can figure them out you can
derive them which is why they've held in
the beginning they didn't hold of course
the metaphysic helped you know at least
people believing that there was so so if
if people believe that someone walked on
water they're far more likely to believe
his pronouncements than if they believe
he didn't walk on water so the
metaphysics is in a sense a way to
concretize and sustain a value
throughout a long period of time but you
can have the same value independent of
whether or not someone walked on water
you could have it independently but it
would it could just as well be
coincidental that you have it
independently and there's no reason why
you you can't argue against that value
so it could be but I mean it certainly
could be
but then again you could reason to
certain values I mean look in a Judicial
System right which by the way sorry go
on no no go ahead well you can reason to
certain values which is exactly why
whenever metaphysic has been removed
from a society or civilization
the those morals completely get twisted
and 100 Hell Breaks yeah no that that's
correct that's that's not an argument
that the the metaphysic is true that's
an argument that it has socially
detrimental effects that's a big
difference sure
so but doesn't that argue against the
idea that that more you could still have
those morals that you would still have
those words because I would say no not
necessarily you wouldn't necessarily
have the same values sorry to use your
word yeah or you can say morals too you
might change it you might be some of
them might be interchangeable and and
coming but I wouldn't say that they are
uh obvious that those morals will uh not
uh
one I don't think one can assume one
would have the same morals yeah no
you're right you're certainly right you
you can assume that you have the same
morals but equally likely why should you
I mean you you you
there is something I find
disturbing
about
believing things that are almost
definitely false so that Society will
function more smoothly
I'm not unsympathetic I guess you know
if my kids were butchered by a lunatic
would I much rather have that lunatic
believe in some kind of metaphysic that
you know a Perpetual fear of hell so
that he didn't do something deranged and
I'd still have my kids well yeah I would
I would so so I think maybe my my to
borrow a term my situatedness
um or maybe as Henderson says that's
just a luxury belief I have I don't know
but there's something
I I just don't think you can compromise
yourself like that I just I just don't I
think to maintain your integrity you
have to believe true things in every
realm like you can't just say well you
know metaphysics you know I'm just gonna
no it just I just think that that said
something pernicious to an individual's
integrity
uh well I'll I'll uh I'll have to um
that's fair enough
um but I would concede that there's an
element of
absolutely an element of faith and I
liked your term earlier that that you
know the notch the the eight of the nine
and yeah yeah I agree with that
um but
um on a positive note yeah if I may all
right so that was a positive note but
okay
not to me
sorry about that
um can you tell me about your uh not for
profit that you've been working on yeah
National progress Alliance and we are a
small non-profit and we
promote free speech in civil discourse
and fight work ideology and all of its
manifestations which are which is the
one thing at this moment that is really
preventing us from seeing more civil a
more civil and just Society so that's
what we do great and small team two
full-time employees and a bunch of
part-time employees wonderful and how
can and people
find out about it and National progress
Alliance and that everything we're 100
donor funded so we do all of the YouTube
videos we that's you know it pays for
stuff we go Reid and I go around the
world reads a volunteer we go around the
world we make videos we give talks we
teach people how to have productive
conversations we teach institutions how
to keep wokeism out how to you know
avoid this madness from infecting their
societies so it's a it's a it's a big
job it's so wonderful to see that after
the the hellish experience you had in
Portland State University that you've
you really like a plane taking off into
the wind it's just now your reach is
global and and you're really putting
everything into before you would trying
to destroy these ideas in the universe
or question them right now you're doing
it on on the world stage and and that's
and that's very inspiring I'm sure a lot
of people are watching you I I
appreciate that I mean I can't do this
alone I have a lot of people who help me
and so you you know this is how like
it's this is not a one-person thing you
really need a community to borrow that
turn of phrase but you actually do need
people and you know we're donor
supported I have an incredibly dedicated
staff and we this is just what we do
full time and I'm incredibly grateful to
be able to do that yeah thanks my dad
just told me make sure you leave the
world better when you left than when you
got in and I think that's what we're
trying to do wonderful stuff well Pizza
pug hoesian thank you so much for your
time thank you fascinating appreciate it
thank you
[Music]